that was a dumb strategy right but i
tripled my money
i tripled my money because i got lucky
if you buy a farm
you know you go up and look you know
every couple weeks to see how far the
corn is up
i'm going to give you something called
the ladder of personal finance
which tells you where your money should
go wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the five
habits that every successful investor
must develop
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one think long term with warren buffett
if you buy a business if you buy a farm
you know
you go up and look you know every couple
weeks to see how far the corn is up and
you know you worry too much about
whether somebody says this is going to
be a year of low prices because
exports are being affected or anything
like that you know you buy a farm
and you hold it for i've got one farm
that i bought in the 1980s and
my son runs it but i've been there once
you know i mean it it it doesn't grow
faster if i go and stare at it you know
i can't cheer for it you know
more effort more effort or something
like that and i know there's going to be
some years when prices are going to be
good and some when the prices aren't
going to be good i know there's years
when yields will be better than others
but about the farm and and uh
if it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions
or anything of the sort i do care that
over over the years it's well tended to
in terms of rotating crops and
i hope yields get better which they
generally have
in fact that farm 100 years ago would
have probably produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices go
back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little
is because we've just gotten better and
better at whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or
soybeans or
all kinds of things and you and i have
benefited from that
and so apple's kind of like a farm well
it's it's a it's a long
term investment and and
if you owned if you own the the best
auto dealership in town
the best brand and had somebody good
running
you wouldn't drop by every day and say
you know how many people have come in
today or
you know i think interest rates are
going up a little maybe that'll slow
down our sales or anything
no you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and
you're going to own it for 20 years so
that's 7 300 days and you know they're
gonna
things are going to be different from
day to day and year to year
you shouldn't buy it if the day-to-day
stuff is important habit number two
build investing discipline with dan lok
you see when it comes to investing do
not get fancy you don't need
sophisticated
complicated techniques if anything you
want to go with something very very
simple something very proven most
wealthy people that i know
they invest in only a number of things
could be real estate could be index fund
could be the stock market their own
businesses that's it they're not chasing
the latest
what you see on social media the latest
investment scheme and things like that
no they only invest in long-term proven
investment vehicles stocks are one of
those vehicles
maybe you're not in a position to invest
in
real estate that's okay you're still
saving up some money when it comes to
creating wealth i want you to understand
something here
skill right skill your investing skill
that's very very critical but what is
more important is
discipline discipline having that
discipline don't get the shiny object
syndrome let's say you could go back in
time you and i could go back in time and
you invest
1 000 in berkshire hathaway
one buffett's company invest in that
stock now at the time the stock was
trading at about 19
a share fast forward today the class a
shares
of berkshire hathaway about three
hundred thousand dollars a share
if back in the days you would have
invest one thousand dollars in berkshire
hathaway
fast forward today do you know how much
that would be worth comment below
that would be worth over 16
million dollars for most people earning
16 million dollars
is virtually impossible by putting aside
000
and you don't even think about it you
don't look at it ever again
and one day you wake up you've got 16
million bucks
in your portfolio but that's not the
most amazing part do you know if you
would have invest
1 000 since 1964
every single year until
today how much that would be worth your
portfolio would be worth
roughly 124
million dollars 124 million dollars
i want you to think about that for a
moment let the numbers sink in
you see the key to creating wealth is
actually very very simple
all you need to do is to earn more money
than what you
actually spend either through a high
income skill or multiple income skills
or
a scalable business that's all you need
to do and then you take the difference
right the spread and you invest the
difference into some kind of investments
solid investments over a long period of
time
that's it nothing complicated about it
there's nothing
complicated about it you see let's say
if you're making 35 000
a year let's say you make 35 000 a year
every single person
has made most people in their lifetime
over a million dollars
you take 35 000 a year you times that by
40 years that's 1.4 million dollars
that's over a million dollars
you have a million dollars slipped
through
your fingers but we just don't know and
we don't have
the habit of investing and that's the
issue
instead of looking for the greatest
investment develop
the best the greatest investing habits
not wait till you have money because if
you're not investing the little bit of
money that you have today
guess what as you make more money you're
not going to invest it it's not going to
happen you're making a thousand dollars
you're not investing a dollar
what makes you think when you make ten
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars
you're going to invest more and more
it's not going to happen you don't
have the habits of investing it's not
about chasing
the latest investments now you may be
thinking so dan what are you
saying you mean all i need to do is just
put a little bit money aside put it in
some kind of
low fee index fund and that's all i need
to do yes
that is exactly what i'm saying that's
it people want all these fancy
techniques and all these things
when you notice when you actually study
how investing works and how wealthy
investors invest
that's exactly what they do they're not
trying to kill the golden goose
that lace the eggs to go buy that
ferrari no
when you have the habit of investing
here's how money works
very interesting when you get how money
works when you
know and when you have the discipline
more money comes to you when you're not
desperate
when you feel secure money is a very
interesting thing when you're putting
money aside
suddenly you have more money and you put
some more money aside and then you have
more money then when you keep improving
and upgrading your skill sets you can
earn more
then you invest more now you can enjoy
life money doesn't go to the people who
need it the most
money goes to people who knows how to
multiply money that's the key
when you understand how this works
everything is simple
hi this is dan lok i want to share with
you a lesson from
evan carmichael's new book built to
serve
this section is about making money from
your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that
is significant one that can pay you so
you can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
build a lot or or build to sell or even
build a scale
it is built to serve and this book will
teach you
exactly how to do that habit number
three
learn from your mistakes with ray dalio
when i was 12
i hated school but i fell in love with
trading the markets
i caddied at the time earned about five
dollars a bag and i took my counting
money
and i put it in the stock market and
that was just because the stock market
was hot at the time
and the first company i bought was a
company by the name of northeast
airlines
northeast airlines was the only company
i heard of that was selling for less
than five dollars a share
and i figured i could buy more shares
and if it went up i'd make more money
so that was a dumb strategy right
but i tripled my money i tripled my
money because i got lucky
the company was about to go bankrupt but
some other company acquired it
and i tripled my money and i was hooked
and i thought this game is easy
with time i learned this game is
anything but easy in order to be an
effective
investor one has to bet against the
consensus and be right
and it's not easy to bet against the
consensus and be right one has to bet
against the consensus and be right
because
the consensus is built into the price
and in order to be an entrepreneur a
successful entrepreneur
one has to bet against the consensus and
be right
i had to be an entrepreneur and an
investor
and what goes along with that is making
a lot of painful mistakes
so i made a lot of painful mistakes and
with time
my attitude about those mistakes began
to change
i began to think of them as puzzles that
if i could solve the puzzles
they would give me gems and the puzzles
were
what would i do differently in the
future so i wouldn't make that painful
mistake
and the gems were principles that i
would then write
down so i would remember them that would
help me in the future
from a very early age the whole idea of
being right is so rewarded
whereas learning
from mistakes doesn't have its place
right you so a kid studies there oh
you're smart smart smart you take the
examination
and okay you do badly and but life's not
like that
life is mostly a matter of making your
mistakes and knowing how to
evolve past those mistakes and learn
habit number four
create the ladder of personal finance
with ramit sethi
what's a few simple things that they
should be doing
right now to have a checklist to do
before the end of the year
to then crush for a whole 12 months
moving forward
all right i'm going to give you
something called the ladder of personal
finance
which tells you where your money should
go okay this is just step by step
put your money here and if you want to
know all the details about it you can
check out the system
so in the book too it's in great detail
in the book got it all right
so if you've got some money lying around
what should you do with it first of all
if you've got a 401k match
at work you should max that out that's
free money take advantage of it
and if you're not sure what that means
go to your hr person and say
does this company match any 401k
contributions
if they say yes do what i said next
if you've got debt pay it off pay it off
aggressively
you know what's interesting is that most
people in debt who i talk to don't
actually know how much they owe
and that's shocking you would think of
course they would no no they don't
because who wants to
stare at their dead all day yeah and
just feel bad about it but you know what
you feel much better when you have a
plan
and the number one question i ask folks
uh when they tell me they have debt i
say number one do you know how much you
owe
they never do number two for the rare
people who say you know fifteen thousand
or
seventy thousand whatever i say what is
your debt payoff date
you can actually plug it in you can pay
uh plug in a debt
payoff calculator online you can map it
all out
and you will be able to know the exact
month your debt will be paid off
based on how much you're spending right
now based on how much you're
contributing to that debt payoff
now you will be able to see that if you
add an extra 50 bucks a month or 100
bucks a month
that thing will actually often times
shorten by years because of the interest
it doesn't matter if it's going to take
you three months or
four years to pay off your debt it
doesn't matter to me what matters is
that you know the date
okay so that's number two pay off any
debt you've got three if you've got
money left over
uh go to your roth i.r.a and if you can
max that out that's a great tax
advantaged accountant it's a crow's tax
deferred is that right yeah yeah
okay so um so that's three that's three
okay it's actually post-tax money
and then four if you've still got money
you're going to go to back to your 401k
which is another tax advantaged account
you're going to max that out
if you still got money you're going to
create a
non-taxable non-retirement account and
just put your money in there
now there's a few other wrinkles to this
there's hsas available
there's also your emergency fund that's
talked about in the book and all these
things there are details
but that just shows you when you've got
money this is where you go there's a
structured way of thinking about it a
ladder towards
a financial success exactly and if you
follow the steps
it's almost like the like a waterfall it
just goes from step one to step two to
step three
and your money's going where it needs to
go automatically and you
will feel great you'll feel great which
is so important and also you're going to
look at your accounts and see
debts going down investment and savings
are going up
and all of a sudden you wake up six
months from now and you're like oh my
god
i didn't realize i have that much saved
in my savings account that's because of
the decision you made today
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is choose your teachers wisely with
robert kiyosaki
the lesson is here you gotta choose your
teachers wisely when the market crashed
in 2008 guess how much money i borrowed
a lot 300 million no way
from investors the banker how does that
how does that work
because interest rates were dropping and
real estate prices were going to the
toilet
and when i walk into my banker this is
what rich dad poured out about british
airport
is about a financial statement income
statement balance sheet statement of
cash flow it's a book on accounting
people don't even know it's a book on
accounting so i walked into my bank with
my partner and had all this property
that was floating to the surface
and i say i'll take them off your hands
i just give give me the money to buy the
property
wow that's cojones 300 million
give me the money and i'll buy your
properties for you
that's crazy so it depends and this is
my whole thing i am now
700 million almost a billion in debt
really you know why because i don't pay
any taxes the more debt i have the less
tax i pay
and the average guy goes how do you do
that because you have bad teachers
and so it's this whole thing that you
got to choose your teachers wisely
that's why i wrote the book fake fake
money fake teachers fake assets
i don't touch that garbage of wall
street puts out i don't have a 401k i
don't have stocks
visual funds etfs doesn't mean you
shouldn't but i don't need them
okay right and the other part is look
for young guys
the best teachers are not on colleges
the best teacher
are on youtube the best teachers are on
youtube
wake up you know this guy is george
gammon he's fantastic patrick beth david
fantastic you know he's great records
the fake teachers are in colleges and
they're telling me to get a job
right the corporate ladder you know
patrick david said it the best
and i love that guy he says there's two
kinds of leaders
wartime and peace time and a peacetime
leader is a guy like my poor death he
goes through all the right schools he
has all the pedigrees the credentials
he does all the right things he climbs
the corporate on the government ladder
and all that
or wartime leader ghost goes to war so
jobs steve jobs the wartime leader i'm a
wartime leader
differences i went to war i went to war
twice on the front lines
yeah and i checked what happened so i
joined the marine corps
i got a flight pull in pensacola i
learned to fly go to camp pendleton
i strap all my weapons i go to advanced
weapons and camp pendleton
i go to okinawa and then they send me
into vietnam
and i came out of vietnam about four
months later
back to back to restage in okinawa and i
thought everybody had changed
i looked at the fellow marines and i
thought
and it wasn't that they were i had been
to war
you got tougher it's different
when somebody's trying to kill you every
single mission i went down three times
no way yeah and i came back stronger and
tougher so i come back to okinawa
i got like a week off and they're going
to ship me back into vietnam again i
said what happened to these guys
and it wasn't that they changed i
changed
so what happens to entrepreneurs who go
out and they get their ass handed to
them and they survive
if you survive you see the world
differently so that's what happened to
you when you get injured and all this
yeah
you see a different world whereas some
peace time
who's climbing the corporate ladder
right now they just lost their job
they're sucking their thumb you know
this is the worst time for them
yet for a wartime leader they're excited
they're excited about it
yeah it's the best of times yeah if
you're an entrepreneur right now
the world's open to you you're an
employee your world's dead to you
yeah an entrepreneur can create their
own success
and for the people that are the wartime
people what is the
the best advice you would give them now
for the next year or two years to
capitalize on how do they make more
money how do they make their millions
during this time
what would you can't make money now you
should hang it up
i i tell all you freaking millennials
man
you got you know i don't know where it
is i got this iphone
if you can't make money with that hang
it up you know like we used to say hang
up the jock strap
you're not gonna make the you can't make
money with an
iphone through social media through
marketing you have the world at your
fingertips
and you can't make money the problem is
between this area and this is not out
here it's in here
that's why you've got to choose your
teachers wisely yeah
you know so let me just say it again the
best teachers are on youtube
so it's the best porno take up your mind
make up your mind which you want to
listen to
you know we have a choice so
yeah i'm just being real to you i hear
you man
i hear you what's what's the best
investment people can make then to
to opera uh capitalizing this
opportunity is the investment in
education left here look if you're poor
right now
it was called look in the mirror that's
what i always said to me says
if you're looking in the mirror right
now and you see a loser
that's what you are you can't make money
in this economy
you better change your thinking you know
you know hindsight is 20 20
as i said yes yes that was if you're
looking you know you don't have any
money you don't have a job
your boyfriend or girlfriend has left
you and uh
soon there goes well how did i get here
how did i get here there was a there was
a great book called uh
you know gulag archipelago by sulza
nathan
so he gets thrown in this in a um
concentration camp or a gulag in siberia
and he says how did i get here you know
how you got there
because he was a peacetime leader didn't
fight back
so people are being sold that they'll go
to school
get a job pay taxes
save money get out of debt
buy a house and your house is an asset
and invest for the long term in a
well-defined portfolio
of stocks bonds mutual funds and etfs
and i do none of that and why do you
recommend
the opposite because i don't have to do
that crap that's that's kool-aid go to
school
go to school what they teach about money
nothing get a job you pay the highest
taxes
pay your taxes i don't pay taxes get out
of debt well debt
money is debt after 1971 if you know
your history of money
your house is not an asset house is a
liability and why would it invest for
the long term in the stock market when i
can make my own assets
i don't need the stock market i'm not
saying you shouldn't but i create my own
assets i create my own cash flow
every day i mean you mean through your
business through your
your right your creativity
i'm an entrepreneur yeah most people are
employees
now i've got a special bonus clip on how
to invest that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know which
of these five habits do you need to
better apply to your life and your
investing
let me know put it down the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here
watching i want to celebrate you because
believe nation we don't just watch
videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag
down in the comments and tell me where
you're from cause i want to celebrate
you and this isn't something i talk too
much about on the channel in terms of
investing i have my own
philosophies and strategies around
investing first off i believe the best
investment you can make is in
yourself as an entrepreneur as a human
being to get better to learn to adapt to
grow
you'll make way more money in your own
company
than you will by investing into a stock
market or
real estate or something else but if
you're starting to make money and
you're you know keeping some pulling off
the table saving for retirement whatever
it is not that
we're really going to retire i think if
you're really a true entrepreneur even
as a using as
a backup plan in case something goes
horribly wrong one of the only true
actual sources of passive income
is investing into the stock market
especially when you don't have to
do anything that's managed right if
you're not buying something you need to
check in on all the time
so you can look at index funds right an
index fund
just matches how the market is doing
and you know the market's going up
you're making more money and
historically the market's going to go up
it'll have down periods but overall it's
going to go up
and you can just keep putting money into
that and it'll keep paying you back but
you don't have to worry about
doing anything if you're managing an
active portfolio then there's a little
bit more work just like the advertising
campaign
but the idea here is you're leveraging
your money
to help you go out and make more money
you know before we were leveraging
our people to be able to be able to
bring more in for our business right so
just another way if you have some money
saved up you can use it to bring in more
money it's not going to be a huge return
on investment
and i still think the best bet is
probably in yourself and your own
business
but it is another way to make money
while you sleep
[Music]
if you want advice from some of the top
investors in the world check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you don't have to be right about
thousands and thousands and thousands of
companies
you only have to be right about a
company couple i met bill gates on july
5th 1991.